I have this dream of doing the spelling
bee on steroids the contestants line up
facing a wheel labelled with a bunch of
the world's languages
step right up spin that wheel and
wherever it happens to land you have to
read a word and write a word in that
languages native writing system whoo-hoo
as a language a nerd there's a lot that
intimidates me about this spelling bee
but I must confess there's one
maniacally tough written language that I
really hope this wheel never lands on
I am excited let's go through and list
why each one of these scripts has some
tricky letters and then at the end I
will reveal to you the language with the
world's scariest spelling number 10 wait
what was that uh come again this just in
but apparently someone else already
answered my question
he swears that the worst script ever is
Thai hmm really I mean I messed with Lao
and Thai a few years ago and yeah they
weren't super easy but Thai okay here's
his complaint see when a written
language grows up and gets old the way
people speak it changes over time but
the way people write the language stays
fossilized the result is historical
spelling and Thai has some blatant
historical spelling not only is written
Thai pretty old but even when it was new
it modeled its letters on Sanskrit so it
inherited fossils from the get-go Thai
has an alpha syllabary with 44 consonant
letters for writing just 21 consonant
sounds plus vowels and tone marks plus a
complicated way of figuring out how all
of those letters work together to tell
you which tone to pronounce on which
vowel yeah but I think this missed the
point what is it about historical
spelling that makes a script tough
consider two people first the reader
won't you consider the reader a script
is hard when I don't know which sound is
safe for the letters I'm about to read
and for the writer this script is hard
if I don't know which letters to use for
the sounds I want to right now glance
back at Thai there's something regular
and predictable about it especially for
the reader we can sum it up in a not too
long page on Wikipedia we can dust our
hands off and set you loose on language
and you should do fairly well in fact I
think of Thai spelling is not too
different from Greek in a way a bunch of
letters come together to represent a
smaller set of sounds it's that same
many to one correspondence all also like
ties some sounds influenced others in
predictable ways and yeah there aren't
those tight owns to deal with but you're
stuck with the Greek tonal system with
its move
accents and double accents based on how
pitch and vowel length used to work way
back in ancient Athens yeah
no no no don't fear tie my friend look
elsewhere it's got mountains it's got
llamas it's got Buddhists talking Dhamma
welcome to Tibet history tells us that
Tibetans have this guy to thank for
writing songs in Gumble pardon the
spelling they're a sneak preview
he brought kingdoms together to form the
vast Tibetan Empire he said hey guys
were Buddhist now and around the Year
6:30 he set a young minister to India to
learn how to write what he brought back
from India was a new Alpha syllabary
just like Tai
they both emphasize consonants and
surround them with vowels they both came
with Buddhism so both have special
conventions for transcribing sacred
Sanskrit terms and nowadays they both
have to deal with tones and convoluted
ways they weren't designed to handle but
written Tibetan has much much older
here's the basics you start with the
base consonants with their built-in
dummy vowels then you learn to write
vowels and woods and rose and use as
little flags on the consonants but it
gets even more exotic Tibetan can stack
consonants you can flip consonants it
can clump together masses of consonants
to build syllables that look like this
this is how to bettan spell these words
and this is how they say them did that
sink in for you this is what people are
reading this is what people are saying
this tangled mess of consonants is why
Yeti yeah J is spelled yeah bread why
the Tibetan languages B even though it's
really Debus and this the name for this
Klingon looking beauty that is the
Tibetan script how do you think it's
pronounced any clue time's up its you
check yeah if you think reading with
these letters is hard
you should try writing with them in
Lhasa the sound stoop might mean any of
these words it might mean overflows
accomplishes those or even other forms
of the verb accomplished like
accomplished and will accomplish but
guess what those are
all spelled differently the puzzles
don't stop take two words with very
similar spelling the one spelled grogs
gets pronounced top and grogs why that's
bro give up yet well there is some logic
here here's the deal
Tibetan has core letters has vowels
around those core letters and then
outside letters and once you grasp that
basic fact you can start figuring out
which letters to ignore like in this
verb that looks like BoSox b is a prefix
and the S is a suffix so you can just
concentrate on getting these middle
letters right suc maybe ok and now
you're thinking I get it it's the vowel
and some other letters in the middle of
the syllable I care about I can just
ignore everything else BAM
I'm Tibetan dangerous strategy there for
two reasons number one you need to know
which letters not to ignore and reason
number two we can't just drop letters
and walk away like that
Tibetan has a complicated relationship
where letters influence the
pronunciation of other letters meaning a
silent letter can still change the way
other letters get pronounced so the name
of one of the major schools of Tibetan
Buddhism is written like this we might
innocently cross out all of these sounds
and say something like Kaku but that
Tibetan ooh actually sounds like the
German you there it acts that way
because of the final D that's after it
Kaku lucky you though Buddha ooh isn't
the only vowel change that works this
way and D isn't the only consonant that
triggers it so yeah you're dropping
letters here you're influencing letters
with ghost letters and sometimes you're
not even just dropping and influencing
you're finding out that whole clusters
of letters interact together to create
totally different sounds complex
patterns it's all complex patterns now
things ratchet up another notch when you
put syllables together sometimes you'll
find a letter that silent likes a silent
R before another consonant in the word J
so you might cross it out and then
forget about it just have it suddenly
pop out at you when you smash it against
another syllable like in this name
keep every little bit of this in mind
when you run crying to your Tibetan
dictionary for help because the Tibetan
idea of alphabetical order is not
organizing words by the first letter no
no no they use that root letter wherever
it happens to be why do you do this to
bed science says that being a
high-altitude mountain people Tibetans
have physiological advantages like
increased blood flow to the brain maybe
they're spending that power on this
bizarre writing system but honestly they
did try to get rid of this bad spelling
Karma really old Tibetan got a spelling
reform in the year 800 and then well
that that was it twelve hundred years
ago think of what's happened in twelve
hundred years the Viking Age the Norman
conquests of England everything ever
written in Thai the last Mayan codices
Chaucer Shakespeare the Tokugawa
Shogunate these are current events
compared to the last time Tibet changed
its spelling
that is some serious historical spelling
and it's why when I'm standing there
watching the wheel clack clack clack
around deciding my fate in that
multilingual spelling bee I really
really hope that wheel doesn't land
Tibet but assuming we're thinking
spelling means segmental scripts ones
where we're matching letters to sounds
but I'm going to step out of the bounds
of this game show here because if we
color outside the mandala lines Tibetan
isn't even the worst offender when it
comes to historical spelling there's a
written language that plays much faster
and looser with its symbols and expects
way more readers and writers than
Tibetan ever could
thanks for joining me in my spelling bee
I really liked having you here stick
around and subscribe for language
I'm Tibetan Aki